la quiebra de silicon Valley Bank y sak
nature Bank representa la mayor prueba
para el sistema financiero
estadounidense desde la crisis de 2008 e
incluso mientras el presidente Joe biden
intentaba restaurar la confianza en el
sector bancario estadounidense admitió
que era necesaria una regulación más
estricta voy a pedir el congreso y a los
reguladores bancarios que refuercen las
normas de los bancos para que sea menos
probable que este tipo de quiebra
bancaria se repita y para proteger el
empleo y las pequeñas empresas
estadounidenses para evitar que se
repitiera la crisis financiera mundial
Washington promulgó la ley dot Frank en
2010 la normativa implementó normas
sobre cómo pueden invertir los bancos
así como los requisitos mínimos para los
activos líquidos también estableció
organismos reguladores para vigilar el
sector de los servicios financieros sin
embargo en 2018 bajo el mandato del
entonces presidente Donald Trump se
debilitaron algunas cláusulas de la dot
Frank bancos como es BB estaban a favor
este retroceso argumentando que no eran
lo suficientemente Grandes como para
justificar la supervisión la medida les
permitió invertir más de sus depósitos y
ganar más dinero para ejecutivos y
accionistas los detractores de la
desregulación entienden que tuvieron la
razón como la senadora demócrata
Elizabeth Warren que mencionó las
quiebras bancarias son el resultado
directo del debilitamiento de las normas
financieras por parte de los líderes de
Washington la secretaría del tesoro de
Estados Unidos Janeth ya se ha mostrado
partidaria de reforzar las competencias
de los organismos reguladores sin
embargo biden se enfrenta a un congreso
dividido lo que podría dificultar la
aprobación de leyes de regulación más es